so radium was the element that was
discovered by Madame Curie and it's
chemistry is very similar to that of
barium except that it is radioactive and
it was used quite widely for treatment
of cancer in the days when radiation was
used radioactivity was used for treating
cancer the idea is that cancer cells
where all cells are liable to be killed
by X or by radiation by radioactivity
when they're dividing so cancer cells
are cells in the body which are dividing
much faster and out of control
compared to other but cells so if you
radiate a patient the tensor cells
because they're dividing faster die
quicker so overall although most a lot
of cells day the cancer cells die
further the people who discovered radium
and the same were really excited about
it and they were mad in well with
hindsight in the way they treated it
they carried sort of little glass tubes
of radium in their pocket and we're then
surprised when they found burns on their
flesh the next day and it's thought that
the reason why many of these researchers
like Madame Curie's husband and Madame
Curie died rather young was from the
effect of the radioactivity of the
elements that they handled well in
general as you go down the periodic
table that the element heavier elements
tend to be more dangerous and but even
some that well the very reactive ones
like fluorine are usually not very
dangerous because they react with
something long before they get into the
body the radioactive elements tend to be
dangerous because they can get into the
body and then when they decay they kill
cells or even worse than killing the
cells is that they change the DNA so
that the cells mutate into some
aggressive form of cancer